FRED CHUNG: Long lasting battery
is the most important factor
for Android users.
And by extension, developers
should care about it too.
While we want to
achieve reliable battery
life for Android, apps
should have some flexibility
to run in the background.
The platform needs to provide
consistent restrictions
as guardrails to prevent
a few misbehaving
apps from draining the battery.
This is important, such that
you can design your apps to run
consistently across devices.
At the same time, users
should have some control
and visibility to
app battery usage.
How does Android balance
these considerations?
From Android Lollipop
to P, the platform
has introduced a
series of features
that aim to offer
power management based
on three main dimensions.
Firstly, device idle
state, or how long
the device has been unplugged
and with the screen off.
The device could enter doze,
where all apps cannot acquire
wake locks.
No job services and sync
adapters can be run.
You are likely familiar
with this already.
The second one is
based on giving users
control and visibility.
There are a couple
of relevant features.
In Android P, battery
saver has been
enhanced for users who want
to have extended battery
life over everything
else, possibly
at the expense of some
feature degradation,
such as restricted location
services during screen off.
Users can turn this
on any time, or set
it to turn on automatically
when the device drops
below a certain threshold.
So developers should account
for these restrictions
and test against them.
There are times when apps might
be too aggressive in acquiring
wake locks, or,
in general, doing
things that are considered
bad for battery drain.
New in P there is the
background restrictions feature.
Based on Android
Vitals, The device
monitors and detects
apps that demonstrate
known bad behaviors,
and flags to the users
who can then choose to restrict
these apps from running
jobs, alarms, background
services, and so on.
Most users only use a small
number of installed apps
regularly.
When you think about
it, the total number
of installed apps
on a device really
should have no correlation
to battery life.
The third dimension aims
to tackle this issue
based on app usage patterns.
In Android P, the system
can, in a fine grained way,
apply restrictions to apps that
haven't been used recently.
Apps are classified
into five buckets,
ranging from active to never.
We call them app
standby buckets.
Apps that haven't been actively
used for a certain time
would be put into an
appropriate lower bucket.
Accordingly, the system
would progressively
differ app tasks,
such as alarms, jobs,
and network access.
Further, the system uses
machine learning techniques
from DeepMind to intelligently
move apps between buckets
in order to achieve
the highest efficiency.
And it gets better over time.
Device manufacturers
can adopt this ML model,
implement their own, or
use the AOSP algorithm.
Various battery
management features
boil down to restrictions
and deferred access
to some combination
of background tasks.
For developers, therefore,
it's important to test
against these
restricted scenarios.
Let's go over some design
and testing best practices.
Ensure proper
testing over a range
of increasing restrictions.
ADB commands are available
to simulate the conditions.
You can simulate doze
using these commands.
You can also exit these states
through similar commands,
available in the developer docs.
How do you test against
app standby buckets?
Since it's based on user
behaviors, which can vary,
expect your apps to be
moved between buckets.
Always assume that
your jobs and alarms
will be deferred, and
ensure that your design can
work under those restrictions.
The good thing is that
most apps will be fine
if they are already
following best
practices, such as using jobs,
or targeting at least API level
26.
Also note that in the
frequent and rare app
standby buckets, high priority
Firebase Cloud messages are
kept, and any messages
beyond the threshold
will be treated as
normal priority, which
could be delayed when
the device enters doze.
Again, test against these
conditions thoroughly.
You can use a couple
of ADB commands
to set and retrieve
buckets for your package.
Before running them, make
sure your device is unplugged.
There are also framework APIs
to get an app's current bucket.
Or you can use
usage stats manager
to query the list of events
associated with your app, which
includes bucket changes.
Want to test under
battery saver conditions?
Yep.
There are ADB commands for that.
If your app uses
location, for example,
you can use this
method to verify
how your app behaves
when it uses location
services during screen off.
When battery saver
is turned on, you
can further save battery by
entering your UI's dark theme
if available.
You can either
check for this mode
explicitly, or respond
to a broadcast.
In the event you need to
refactor existing background
surfaces, in most cases the
new WorkManager API can be
used to fulfill many use cases.
Use only foreground services
for user triggered actions
and that users expect
them to run immediately,
such as music playback.
By the way, it's good
practice to also include
a stop [INAUDIBLE]
instant notification.
We have talked about some design
and testing best practices.
During development
and post-launch
there's a couple
of related tools.
The energy profiler
is a new feature
available in Android
Studio 3.2, currently
on the Canary channel.
After you deploy your app
to a connected device,
the profiler shows
a live timeline
of how your app uses
system resources,
such as partial wake locks,
wake up, alarms, jobs,
and location requests.
The profiler also estimates
your app's energy usage
of CPU, network, and
location resources.
Refer to energy profiler
documentation for more details.
In the Play Developer
Console, Android Vitals
exposes performance
metrics that are tightly
associated with battery usage,
which includes excessive wake
ups, stuck wake locks, and
background network access.
Refer to Vitals documentation
for more detail.
With standard ways to manage
power intensive tasks,
and with proper
testing, developers
can create apps that work
consistently across devices,
and collectively can achieve
good battery life for users.
To learn more about
these features and tools,
check out the links below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]